An ideal quantum computer can break the encryption
standards we use today by finding prime factors
of a large integer in just minutes instead
of the thousands of years it would take for
a classical computer to do.
But before you start to panic, while we have
real quantum hardware today,
it's not quite powerful enough to do that
just yet.
However, technologies are advancing faster
than ever.
The cell phones we have today are more powerful
than the mainframes that we used to send people
to the moon.
And the researchers believe that we will soon
be entering an era of quantum advances where
quantum computers will be used to accelerate
classical computers, just like GPUs.
In this video, I'm going to talk about five
foundational topics in quantum computers:
superposition, gates, measurement, interference,
and entanglement.
But before we dive into that, let's first talk
about bits.
Classical computers that use bits which are
like switches that can be a 0 or a 1.
This way of computation has served us well.
So well, in fact, that almost all modern computers
work this way.
However, this approach doesn't solve all the
problems that we have today -- problems that
can blow up exponentially and would take a
classical computers decades or more to solve.
We already talked about the algorithm we
use for encryption.
Other types of difficult problems include
optimization, chemistry simulation, and machine
learning.
Now let's talk about our first topic, superposition.
A quantum computer does not use the simple 0
and 1 bits.
Instead, it uses qubits.
Qubits can be a 0, a 1, or any linear combination
of the two.
This spectrum of states is what we called
a superposition.
Our next next topic is about gates.
Similar to classical computers, we use -- we
string together qubits using a construct
called gates that can alter the states of qubits into
circuits.
For example, we can have a qubit
that's at the state of 0.
Then we can use Hadamard gate, or H gate for short,
to put it in a superposition between 0 and 1.
And, of course, you can have multiple qubits
with multiple gates in a circuit.
For the circuit will be useful, at some point
that you need to read about its outputs.
Which brings us to our next topic, measurement.
When a qubit is measured, it loses its superposition
and collapses into just a simple 0 or 1. That means
an arrow pointing this way does not measure
a 0.5,
instead, it has a 50% chance of measuring
a 0 and 50% chance of measuring a 1.
It is this in-between state that sometimes
people say that a qubit can be a 0 and a 1
at the same time.
It also means that just a small number of
qubits can represent a large amount of information.
So for our next topic, interference,
we begin by addressing a common problem --
common question -- why is it that quantum
computers can outperform classical ones?
So, if you remember, a quantum state is
a linear combination of the 0 state
and the 1 state.
So, an operation applied to this can be seen
as applying to the 0 state and the 1 state,
doing two calculations at once.
It is this parallel computation that gives
quantum its unique advantage.
However, as you may recall, when a qubit is
measured, it loses its superposition and collapses
into 0 or 1.
That means we can only get a single answer
instead of all the answers from this parallel
computation.
And to make sure the single answer we get
is a correct one,
quantum gates need to be arranged in a way
so that
it would amplify the correct answer and cancel
all the incorrect ones.
A process called interference.
Now this leads us to our last topic, entanglement.
When qubits are entangled, their states become
strongly correlated.
That is, changing
the state of just one qubit would change
the state of another.
For example, we can entangle two qubits so
that their states have 50% chance of measuring
a 00 and 50% chance of measuring a 11, but
never a 01 or a 10.
In this case, if we just -- if we change just
the state of one, the other one would
also change.
So with the combined power of superposition,
interference,
and entanglement,
quantum computers can solve things that classical
computers simply cannot do today.
It can lead to better drug -- better drug discovery --
or enhance the stock portfolio or even artificial
intelligence.
Now we just need to wait for the quantum hardware
to catch up.
Thanks for watching.
If you have any questions, please leave them
in the comments below.
Also, please remember to Like this video and
Subscribe to our channel so we can continue
to bring you content that matters to you.